the port of los angeles will launch 24 7
operations to tackle the huge line of
ship ships waiting to dock the white
house says insider story the port of la
is starting to process ships 24 uh 24
hours a day seven days a week to help
ease a massive backlog the white house
said wednesday the new hours would most
almost double the number of hours during
the which cargo can be moved it said the
shipping industry is currently in chaos
which ports in southern california hit
especially hard at the port of la alone
ships current carrying nearly 500 000
shipping containers
containers by the way each one of them
are right now what's the number she said
40 grand a pop 500 000 containers at 40k
a pop or about 12 million metric tons of
goods were waiting in drift areas at an
anchor
on october 5th for spots to open up so
that they could dock and unload on
tuesday there were 80 ships at anchor or
drift area and 64 adverts across both
the ports of la and long beach the
normal number of container ships at
anchors between zero and one yesterday
saki was being asked if uh if things are
not going to be delivered by christmas
and they promise this will never happen
this will never happen and then she
changed her position so well there's
nothing we can do about this people are
just going to have to accept that you're
not going to have that's right
so can you imagine like
hey you ordered if you want to get gifts
for your kids you got to get them now
because if you wait till december you
are not it's going to be january 17th
you're going to get the gifts to give to
your kids so this is a big deal this is
a big deal my mom actually worked in
cargill services for a company called
sealand csx lines horizon lines that now
has been acquired by matson
and she worked with the longshoremen uh
wednesday nights friday nights just to
make sure that she would watch
physically see with the longshoremen the
last container to be on that ship and
i've been to panama got to see the canal
understand that yeah the money that is
probably being
um
the people who own the ports have to
charge these people for the ships not
leaving
so there's a cost in that as well that
is going to be
driven to the consumer eventually
and it's not going to look good for
people
at all at all the the those uh shipyards
that whatnot they're making the money
right now but i don't know how that's
being dispersed yeah but typically when
someone charges one individual it always
gets hit with us and then you got people
in government that say oh yeah you know
you're not gonna be able to get stuff
it's like man it's beyond that you're
talking about medical supplies you're
talking about a lot of different things
and uh that that the future does not
look bright
and until they get a handle on this
thing
i said something earlier man i love this
line you said
i don't come from the hopeless the
helpless community i don't come from the
helpless community it's a great line and
you got jen sackey up there who has all
the access the power of the united
states government could declare a state
of emergency they're going to fire all
the nurses and the doctors and they're
not worried about that because we're
going to replace them with the national
guard well the national guard could
unload trucks the national guard could
unload ships don't don't give me this
people are just gonna have to accept
christmas is canceled this year no
unload the ships who said christmas is
cancelled gensake i'm i am she said yeah
i'm being hyperbolic
but that was a conversation because
because a lot of these bigger
corporations are saying
listen
some of the stuff may not make it to the
stores like you have to be prepared for
it someone said there's going to be a
big delay on that it's not this is not
like a hypothetical this effects
everything this is business yeah this is
affecting everybody so this is the part
where dude did you hear the weight 500
000 containers which is how many tons
did it say what was the tons it was one
point what one problem
twelve million million metric tons of
goods yeah twelve million metric tons of
goods so businesses wanna sell i had a
guy that i was the the kai the guy that
would we had an elite mastermind he says
i sell
cigarette lighters
but he buys quarter million of them and
these cigarette lighters have team logos
on there lakers bowls whatever right
anybody does he says my 250 000 lighters
have already been sold but my customers
are asking for the money back because
it's been 90 days because it's sitting
on a ship yep and i can't take it off
this is not a millionaire he does 400
000 a year and he nets like 120 000 so
it's not like he's a guy making a lot of
money right he has no control over that
what does he do this is affecting a lot
of small business owners normally you
would have to like in the supplement
business it's kind of the same thing
you know you have distributors whatnot
and a lot of the time if you're good
those same distributors sell to those
stores so therefore
by the time the ship actually hits the
port of that destination
everything's already sold you know like
everybody makes their money but in this
case like you just said i mean this guy
now has to have
to
pay back if he even does and this is
going to [ __ ] his business i
literally just did this i got the custom
chucks man and i ordered two more of
them and it's been six weeks i just put
in like last two and they're not
answering my emails they're not putting
in the refund requests the [ __ ] my
chucks are probably sitting on a chip a
ship in the port of l.a that is crazy
and you can't even pay you came in
that's one ship
okay one ship can put eleven hundred
boeing 747 planes on there
what essentially what what this means
are you kidding the capacity goods on
that ship would take 1100 planes to get
it down
it would take 35 8 000 foot long trains
it would take eleven thousand four
hundred heavy trucks these ships are a
big deal i think i think i remember
kai look this up because i don't want to
get this wrong wow but each
uh transcontinental trip that they take
from from china let's say to the west
coast i think it's the equivalent
in carbon emissions of like a million
cars
each of these boats i could be wrong
because i know that sounds crazy they
burn they burn worse fuel they burn
diesel they burn like the crappiest fuel
because they can do that
and they're just they're sitting but out
there just burning this stuff up it's
still the most efficient way to move it
like there's no way what are you gonna
do about it we haven't figured out a
better way well there's nothing we can
do look at not a shipping expert over
here but what's the root cause of this
what's the supply chain issue are these
trade policies are these
uh is this covid that's getting in the
middle like why why is this all
happening
one of the things that they're saying is
people are not showing up employees
lack of getting it's what we're talking
about people are not showing up to come
and do the work but it's a it's a
backlog even though people are showing
up now yeah it's a backlog of six months
of people not sure this is a systematic
of what happened during covet
unemployment people sitting at home
people not showing up to work people not
moving things okay this is building so
as people as people get back to work
this can get rectified soon is this is
there end in sight here what's the
what's the give me a silver lining here
since we're not helpless or hopeless go
hit kai yes and no obviously if you're
if you're not in the short term
yeah if you're if you're putting in the
same amount of 40 hours of week but
you're trying to catch up on six months
of backlog then obviously it's gonna
take a long time to speed that up so
unless you're filling up to try to catch
up it's gonna be a long time and at that
point you might as almost try to trash
it because who knows what the goods of
how long they're shopping for if there's
perishable goods no you these like well
you're taking i already said there's
additional shipping costs now you're
going to pay overtime to the long story
almost all are you think about the
perishable goods so if you have a
product like i'm always going to go back
to sports nutrition
from manufacturing data it's two years
so you've got six months or whatever i
mean it's going to take
maybe a couple months just to have it
arrive
so you lost two months there
do the math
these guys the minute the protein gets
there or whatever how does that person
sell it
because the mag because the person
that's buying is going to be like oh
this expires in like six months what's
the time to be in logistics too my
buddy's in logistics
ex pro ball player and like uh
name's james what's he said great dude
so he does trucking logistics yeah he
somehow i don't know it exactly but he
matches up trains to to trucks
and it's there it's a bidding war right
now there's so few there's so few
truckers and everybody is trying to
force their products out on overnight
delivery because they're running up
against their their delivery dates
there's a certain amount of shelf life
that they have to be on so they're
they're charging like 10 20 000 for a
single ride up from like jacksonville to
like charlotte man like it's insane
crazy you know how inflation sometimes
is so complicated this is very simple
inflation
because the cost is getting passed down
to who to the business owner and the
business owner is like i can't sell this
thing for seven bucks i got to make it
8.99 i got to make it 9.99 i can't do
nothing about that so these are the
things that is not even linked to
printing money these are the things that
sometimes you just don't have a choice
the small business world is right now
in shambles try your fruit man
certain
yeah
work in sports nutrition that actually
will say i have the money
to to ship it by air because it needs to
be climate controlled
but damn everybody can't do that yeah so
i mean
it's uh it's really interesting man it's
an interesting thing because
going back to our administration
whenever it comes down to restricting
the rights of individuals they can't
wait to jump they cannot wait to jump
but anytime you need to do the other
side of the pendulum and help people and
like hey let's let's have a solution
that doesn't increase my power they have
absolutely no ideas on how to do it hey
how do we how do we shut down a city i
got 15 ideas on how we're going to do it
everybody's going to wear masks now all
these businesses that have been open for
six months they've got to go outside
build a tent outside because as long as
you're inside outside it's okay they've
got all these ideas but when it comes to
actually being progressive and pragmatic
they got nothing but kiss what it is
sorry christmas is canceled what do you
mean unload the ships so if you enjoyed
this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch or if you want to see
the entire podcast click over here take
care everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you